en Colombia esta ha sido una semana
complicada para el presidente Gustavo
Petro al que le han abierto distintos
frentes con crisis ministerial protestas
campesinas y sospechas de corrupción en
contra de su familia para analizar todos
estos eventos tenemos en nuestro plató a
nuestro periodista ius Muñoz ellos Muñoz
buenos días qué tal Rosa cómo estás bien
una semana complicada como decíamos con
muchísimos frentes para Petro tú misma
lo dices podemos decir que estamos ante
una de las semanas más críticas desde
que Petro es presidente en la que ha
habido de todo desde tres destituciones
ministeriales e incluso una batalla
tuitera entre Petro y su contraparte de
Salvador nayib bukele como son muchos
frentes empecemos concentrándonos por
una de las noticias también y ha sido un
informe no del comité de derechos
humanos de Naciones Unidas que mezcla
esperanza y condena hacia Colombia no
2022 uno de los años más violentos pero
también dice este comité que tiene fe
esperanza no en el plan de paz total de
este gobierno de Petro Así es Rosa Este
informe anual del alto comisionado de
los Derechos Humanos estuvo presentado
por la representante Juliette de Rivero
en el que dijo que había aumento de la
violencia en 2022 acercándonos a cifras
similares a las de antes del acuerdo de
paz entre el estado y las FARC de 2016
centrándonos en estos datos podemos ver
como los líderes sociales hubo 116
asesinatos en 2022 un incremento a los
100 de 2021 también las masacres pasaron
de las 78 de 2021 a las 92 de 2022
también hubo 50 excombatientes de las
farcas asesinados y ya son 355 al menos
los asesinados desde el año 2016 en el
que hubo la firma del acuerdo de paz
también hubo 103 miembros de la fuerza
pública asesinados y otro aumento en el
número de desplazado de 72.000 pasamos a
82.000 por lo que como decías Julie pero
se mostró preocupada pero también
esperanzada entre esas reformas que el
gobierno de Gustavo Petro quiere
acometer como entre ellas la paz Total
que busca la fin del conflicto a seis
décadas después de seis décadas y en la
que también Juliette de Rivero dijo que
esto estas reformas van a necesitar
tiempo en relación a esta Esperanza que
comentas no y Luis precisamente el
presidente Gustavo Petro en medio de
este aluvión de problemas se felicitó
ayer felicitó concretamente al
Ministerio de defensa y de interior no
por la liberación de los 79 policías y
seis civiles que como avanzábamos en los
titulares de este informativo fueron
liberados ayer viernes después de ser
retenidos el jueves en medio de una
protesta campesina profundicemos en esto
sí así es San Vicente del caguán es un
municipio ubicado en el Sureño
departamento del caquetá que es la
puerta de entrada al amazonas y que
destacamos que es bueno era uno de los
bastiones de las FARC allá Durante un
mes hubo protestas campesinas
debido a que una empresa petrolera
emeral Energy que es una filial de una
petrolera china no había cumplido con
los compromisos de 42 kilómetros de
pavimentación de una vía maltrecha por
todo el tipo de cargas que salen de las
instalaciones petrolíferas Entonces el
jueves escaló la situación y los
campesinos llegaron a retener a 79
policías y seis civiles como comentabas
finalmente en la intermediación que hubo
con el los ministerios y con los
distintos funcionarios fueron liberados
estas personas y Petro dijo este es un
gobierno para dialogar este es un
gobierno que les pertenece y se
comprometió a visitar la zona para
continuar con esas negociaciones Cabe
destacar que estas tipo de disputas son
habituales en Colombia y es que muchas
multinacionales extractivistas causan
ciertos daños medioambientales que
afectan a las comunidades que no ven
como hay beneficios para ellas por esta
actividad multinacional también Cabe
destacar Que bueno hay
un enfrentamiento también de entre las
disidencias con el estado y no están
avanzando las negociaciones por lo que
también se cree que detrás de estas
protestas disidencias de las extintas
FARC estarían detrás Okay es muy
interesante y precisamente para salir un
poco al paso continuar con poder
continuar con sus políticas y dejar de
lado un poco las críticas quizás más
personales en el seno de su familia como
avanzábamos no Petro sorprendió con una
comunicado en el que pide a la justicia
colombiana que Investiga a su hermano y
a su hijo y nos ha traído una portada
del espectador bastante ilustrativa con
esta última polémica no veamos esta
portada del espectador donde se ve en
primer plano a Gustavo Petro detrás a su
hijo Nicolás Petro y titulan con un
contundente a sus espaldas Y es que el
jueves Gustavo Petro emitió un
comunicado en el que pedía la fiscalía
que investigase a su hijo Nicolás Petro
pero también a su hermano Juan Fernando
Petro al parecer Nicolás Petro habría
beneficios presidenciales a
narcotraficantes Y paramilitares a
cambio de dinero que financiaría la
campaña de Gustavo Petro sin embargo
Esto fue revelado por la exmujer de
Nicolás petrol en la revista semana
sería Nicolás Petro quien se quedó esos
fondos y no fueron destilados finalmente
para la campaña en el caso del hermano
Juan Fernando Petro la fiscalía le está
investigando por haber prometido
beneficios judiciales a paramilitares y
narcotraficantes para entrar dentro de
la paz total a cambio de pagos el alto
comisionado para la paz de Colombia ha
confirmado uno de estos casos por lo que
como decía también el diario El País en
su Artículo decían como que Gustavo
Petro a diferencia del filósofo alberca
mis en lugar de escoger entre Cuando
decía que entre la justicia y su madre
escogía a su madre Gustavo Petro entre
su familia y la justicia ha escogido la
justicia en este caso Bueno lo necesita
también para ser coherente digamos no
con a sus promesas y
Pues eso no con la campaña y con la
política que ha prometido el presidente
de Colombia que asumió el cargo
recordemos el pasado mes de agosto